hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage the show where we sit down
with your favorite comedians and find
out if they grew up classy or if their
trash man no two ways about it
I'm your host stage Foley coming at you
on a beautiful day here in my mom's
basement writing out the pandemic move
to higher ground feeling good outside
sunshine play with the dog fantastic my
co-host is coming at you from an
undisclosed location somewhere southern
New Jersey ladies and gentlemen mr.
Kevin James everybody hey gang happy to
be here down here in Casablanca studios
yet again held up there I'm the king of
the boardwalk down here baby and I'm
loving every [ __ ] minute of it
I got a residency on the Gravitron just
[ __ ] looping down here guys thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate review subscribe on iTunes and
also full videos available on YouTube
please subscribe there and shout out to
everybody who already has subscribed and
commenting their own questions and stuff
and also you can submit your own
questions via email to ru garbage at
gmail.com i guess 'sir very nice Thank
You Kippy very special guest on the
podcast today so excited to sit down and
talk to her you've seen her on HBO she's
been a writer for the hit show taffy and
the juggernaut in practical jokers she's
a stand-up comedian who's all over the
country one of my absolute favorites but
the question everybody's mine here today
is she garbage ladies and gentlemen
concoction everybody oh thank you oh my
gosh thank you everyone
Wow you
good camera in a setup yeah really what
kind of MacBook are you working off of
well this is gonna be the first answer
to whether I'm garbage I have a MacBook
that I stole oh that's it I'll pull the
plug that's it that's a wrap on this one
yikes who'd you steal it from I mean I
don't know if I technically stole it but
the company I work for isn't a company
anymore so I took the loaner what can I
say thank you yeah I [ __ ] them when
they're feds are rolling in you grab
everything you can you start stealing
staplers and monitors I took [ __ ]
dehydrated fruit it was pathetic
we all saw a boiler room you [ __ ]
keep it moving if you're not leaving
without a full trunk you're [ __ ] up
you gotta steal from work everybody
steals work yeah I have that man I got
one of those little ring lights because
I I'm on tik-tok now my room my parents
are really want me to have a child or be
married but I'm Erin doing tik-tok
learning the savage I know a little bit
about I know you're from Florida right
all right just tell me about your
childhood how you grew up where you grew
up
sure yeah I grew up in Melbourne Florida
Palm Bay Florida it's a little bit south
of Orlando okay and I live with my mom
and my stepdad and my my birth father is
he lives like 30 minutes away from us in
Sebastian and I think you're gonna say
your birth that also lives with you I
was like wow oh that's happened before
too I don't think you guys understand
like this I I couldn't be more perfect
for this podcast my entire life is I
have nothing else but being trashy
well kippis parents are divorced too and
didn't your old man live like down the
street from you for a little while for a
while I mean he's with her he's within a
couple of minutes like for sure Harry
and Christmas present
his house your room dude its I'm pretty
sure he did it out of spite for the you
know for the longest time for us to be
like we couldn't get out of town without
any of he would just hang out out front
the whole time
make sure you would see my mom drive by
smoking real slow now Kim settle this
for me I have this big thing it could
just be the fact that I'm garbage from
Pennsylvania the way I understand it now
your your town in Florida is by the
coast right it's near the water
why people aren't the people who lived
in the land lock towns and cities in
Florida more trashy and more garbage
than people on the coast absolutely
we're not on the coast I mean we're a
20-minute drive from the coast we're
deep enough we're like we're on the edge
of trashiness that's fair enough
20 minutes is fine but like and the
reason it comes up because when I was a
kid I used to hear about people going on
vacation to a place called Kissimmee st.
cloud isn't that landlocked or is that
on the coast
that's like Orlando you're going to
Orlando yeah okay
as I always thought that is like if you
go to Florida on vacation and it's not
near the water if you just go to Florida
you're [ __ ] garbage it horrible who
would ever do that that's like going to
New York and going to [ __ ] Albany
like who would ever [ __ ] do that
right staying in Queens hi I'm doing a
podcast if you remember earlier when I
was like I'm gonna do a podcast so
nobody come in the room or sit on right
next to me on my bed and peek over who
is it
that's my mom oh hi mom I guess we got
this show wrapped up I tell you I can't
work here anymore
I have no career I can't even pretend
that something's happening it's so funny
the way your mom just slowly came in to
start plugging something come down to
read his nails or so you know any nook
out Sheree's berries everybody oh the
worst thing I ever did during his
pointing to show my mom chatroulette
wait that's still up dude now I walk
into her and she's like this I thought
it was all peepees on there oh my god
come in my room with a stranger on the
contras oh this is my daughter she was
on Comedy Central and she'll put me on
the phone with a stranger who knows like
my work who's watching me in my
childhood bedroom with like the blinds
like unmatching and I'm like I don't
want to talk to someone who knows me
through comedy right now in this state I
don't need a FaceTime me with people who
know my comedy [ __ ] great your mom's
trying to traffic here something that's
like a reverse taken you say she's
bombing unzoom I'm gonna tell them the
Rogan story if you don't get out then
get out okay you just you just pulled
the [ __ ] a bomb on your mouth I'll
tell the Rogan story mom drop in on are
you garbage a [ __ ] a first my mind my
mind is blown right now this is [ __ ]
awesome I had to make I came down me and
my girl were and we wrote it out in the
story of for like you know the first two
months but then after that we gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here so we can hear
Sunday there is some adjustment when
you're back in here and doing stuff cuz
they don't understand what we're doing
they don't think any of this is work
yeah this is this is gonna be just as
equally trashy but I I don't know what
time is anymore but I know that I've
been in Florida for two menstrual
periods taking it back before there was
calendar you're like I will six periods
I've I arrived six periods ago
long were you gone to boxes of tampons
okay I'm leaving my [ __ ] out in the Sun
seeing which direction it goes we're
gonna leave here at high noon get my
pants back on and we'll be on our way is
that the house that you were raised in
the one year and now no oh can you hear
them fighting so what was the story you
were gonna tell I'm sorry you were ready
to tell something what the Rogen story
Oh
my mom my mom came to a show when I was
opening for Rogen in Orlando she would
hate that I'm even telling you this
anyways but she she came to a show and
afterwards we're all like hanging out
and she asked Rogan if she could tell
him a joke dude I wouldn't quit I would
have been a [ __ ] god oh my god no I
was like this next her I was like
watching I was like what are you gonna
say cuz he knows you know he went now
I'm good oh my mom's face my mom's face
I was like I literally looked at her and
I was like how'd that feel like I told
you not to do something stupid and she
hates that story I don't even think she
can like listen there look at Rogan
anymore funny but we all have to learn
that lesson you know and that was hers
where's your mom from my mom is Puerto
Rican but she's been living in Florida
since I was born so for about 17 and a
half years and did you go to school down
there um did I go to school in Florida
yeah yeah I went to school I went to the
University of Florida for three and a
half years I dropped out my last
semester after I went up at the Comedy
Store one summer during an internship
okay
jackpot that's what I was looking for my
top three answers are either Florida
Miami or her Florida State that's what I
was looking for yeah I'm a University of
Florida dropout hmm Miami is the most
trashy now that's trashy to me because
again I'm older from Pennsylvania when I
think of like trashy football I think
the Miami Hurricanes in the 90s the town
I'm from is so trashy that Miami is
classy geez these rich guys over in
Miami yeah one time like the news said
this thing that they were like looking
up the top US cities that drink the most
alcohol and ours was like third
that's dude from doing the road so much
there's so many every time you go to
like some shitty town they always have
like their claim to fame
it's always embarrassing we got more
[ __ ] [ __ ] per square alright let's
get into some questions here we're gonna
ask you a series of questions to
determine whether you're garbage or not
gotta be honest as your representative
take a plea deal right now and get this
over with
I can't leave I can afford a
representative the state appointed one
to you alright
Kip you want to sell Ralphie when you
started off let's start off with some of
the basics that we kind of normally hit
Dubrow interested yeah you grow up it
wasn't like a single-family home or an
apartment what was it as in childhood
which house either one next question
I mean out of the fort's how many times
did you move a lie I don't even remember
of all our houses I mean even from all
that time I was in high school we had at
least six or seven holy [ __ ] who are you
running from
yeah that's move a lot my parents I've
been gone in New York and this is the
third house I visited them in my mom and
myself I'd like to break up a lot and
then buy individual houses and then get
back together and then move into one of
them sure is your stepdad Puerto Rican
they're Cuban said that's white is white
guy my dad is white too
they're both white and leaf surfers yeah
and they're really good friends and they
both don't like my mom Internet the plot
thickens like a [ __ ] daytime soap
opera no this is great
this is like a telenovela I love it I
think I have this whole thing already in
a pitch packet you're in there yeah I'm
store are you left-handed I am mm-hm
I've have a garbage person thing
left-handed not good Kippy you're not
left-handed are you know I'm like a
little Maina
my fan I come from a good family but I
was just talking my mom my mom my mom's
left-handed but she said she grew up in
like the 50s in Philly and Catholic
school and they would the nuns would
beat it out of you and just make you
write with your right hand
Jesus Christ like God intended just like
God intended yeah just [ __ ] hit you
with a ruler and say the one thing that
really cares about exactly yeah that was
the worst thing going on in that church
was my mom ready left-handed apparently
yeah medieval times you're left-handed
you're getting burned at the stake in
two seconds you can [ __ ] a kid but you
can't smudge your help
okay all right I got it I got one for
you I'm growing up if you guys use like
disposable plates where they paper or
styrofoam I could literally go grab all
the styrofoam cups and plates in my
kitchen right now
right now our foam is [ __ ] trash when
I tell you I don't know my family's face
when I tried to describe to them that
they should stop buying styrofoam and
they were like alright well who's gonna
pay three more dollars for a paper
plates every time oh my god it's theirs
you know how many mornings we're rolling
to going over like an aunt's house and
she give you a Styrofoam plate I tried
to cut it and like syrup would be
leaking through the pond to the table
trying to have my [ __ ] waffles yeah
big breakfast yeah real garbage move is
when you put the two plates like me make
a sandwich out of them to keep it like
covered that's real garbage yeah all
right I got a follow-up to that as well
at any point did this was this was rich
kid [ __ ] I feel did you ever have like
the little disposable cups in the
bathroom so you could like rinse your
mouth out and throw the cup out right
now we have well water power every time
I shower it smells like I showered in
egg yolk eggs I don't know what to tell
you it's my new scent now it's in my
skin oh and only the water is only
coming out of half of the showerhead cuz
it's so rusted Jesus Christ this is
crazy
dude I remember I've gone to my
my slipper my buddy Matt's house he had
those little cups in the morning I
thought thought I was at the [ __ ] Taj
Mahal was [ __ ] clean living
you guys God came I'm sorry let me give
you a little peek of this curtain if
it's a bedsheet what it is like you'll
understand man see the chair oh that's
an outdoor chair inside inside
I'll do the rip in the blind that's
where you peek out for the cops the
broken behind
that's the lookout right there no lights
because we got the hurricane shutters up
all year round like you know how people
do that with Christmas lights they just
leave someone wants to rob this house
that's [ __ ] great all right now that
doesn't matter I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna count that as garbage but let me
know like your blinds behind New Year's
look nice but my parents dropped a drop
ceiling and the Holies currently
underground by the way that's that
windowsill starts at five feet high
right yeah that's garbage holy living
like a king he's in his mom's mancave I
don't know that's the most embarrassing
thing about it you got a pool table down
here she's right next right next to him
smoking Marlboro 100 growing up would
you keep syrup in the refrigerator you
keep it in the cabinet what about
ketchup would you keep ketchup in the
cabinet or keeping the refrigerator
catsup in the fridge syrup in the
cabinet yeah all right classy I like it
there are some family there's some
families that have it twisted yeah they
keep ketchup in the cabinet [ __ ] you're
sick as [ __ ] if you keep warm ketchup in
cult cult the ones cool who wants nice
warm pancakes with melted butter and
then put cold syrup on top of them
garbage that's who wants it absolute
garbage I'm actually shocked we don't do
that growing up growing up I had a
friend who kept his butter in the
cupboard so they could spread it on
toast he's away dude I was like I I was
like [ __ ] that I'm like I'm getting
buddy [ __ ] and [ __ ]
even dude Wow now you can keep butter
out in a container on on the counter you
can no we don't but you can ya know
that's Norbit
that's not garbage the containers
covered it looks nice and it is easy to
put on toast you don't the [ __ ] fight
the butter everytime you very much
dairies be kept cold that's i don't
count butter as dariya don't look like
milk
well cheese doesn't look like milk
either but that's very nice not in this
house
speaking of milk this is an appropriate
question two-part question one growing
up did you have milk with dinner yes of
course garbage and my second question
probably had it on New Year's Eve have
you have you as an adult ever bought
less than a half a gallon of milk ever
buy a quart yes ask me what I had for
breakfast every day during high school
corn pops that was like I want to know
what your favorite cereal is close well
my favorite cereal oh man that's hard I
like I mean I'm a la I like a Lucky
Charms right now I'm a Kellogg's [ __ ]
but that's cuz I'm getting old how
long's what like a Kellogg's you know
there's like the ones with the dried
strawberries in them special
that's the breath the breakfast the
kings right there you know I don't know
like I've grown up a little it's mature
it's sweetened those special K's up a
lot over the years they were terrible
now they're awesome the fact that my
family thinks their diet foods for sure
that was a diet cereal my mom was like
you could do a whole thing where you
just eat this cereal in lose weight I
was like no you can't dude she's like it
says it on the box I'm like it's their
box I know it's the Special K challenge
it's the Special K diet
dude I was on that for most of high
school my mom my mom's like it'll work
I'm lost like [ __ ] 325 pounds my get
a working thoughts yeah
that's up there did you do your parents
have reduced slimfast my mom did to show
you how trashy and
can I was I would get home from school
nobody would be home I would drink slim
fast and he [ __ ] Snyder's pretzels as
a snack I thought it was like a milk she
didn't realize it was a meal in a can
well yeah we did Weight Watchers over
here mm-hmm that's still pretty big no
Weight Watchers is huge yeah Oprah does
it open yeah did you ever do like him
one of those like neutral systems where
they sang in the food to your front door
have to go to you'd have to go like
[ __ ] Walmart and go in the frozen
food section with this little pamphlet
that told you all the points everything
had oh my god god Kippy why I guess why
were on food I got a couple more oh yeah
I didn't wait I didn't tell you what I
ate every morning oh yeah yeah yeah Oh
every day before school this is freshman
year to senior year every day I would
stop no probably started in sophomore
year I would stop at 7-eleven in the
morning I would get to uh chicken and
Monterey Jack cheese taquitos off the
Rolly thing a bag of the ruffles the
[ __ ] I forget which ruffles they were
this hour in the shredder yes those
ruffles and a coke Slurpee and that was
my breakfast going to school every day
dad and socks cough and scratch-offs
holy [ __ ] you should be the governor of
Florida that's [ __ ] insane
I know this my state oh my god first of
all I loved every single one of those
items you need a breakfast I would go if
I could get my hands on this minute I
would do it but holy [ __ ] that's insane
because it's breakfast it's garbage let
me tell it you something to both you
something and anybody listen to this
the gentleman's move the classy move is
always the coca-cola Slurpee that's the
[ __ ] gentleman you mix in flavors and
[ __ ] like an [ __ ] child [ __ ] coke
or cherry and you keep it [ __ ] moving
alright to everyone yeah that is
incredible I actually because I had a
coke slippery every day in school and I
was in TV production so
the thing in the morning where you watch
the students on TV be like anchors and
like talk about what's going on the
school yeah our teacher for the end of
the year she did like a surprise thing
where she did bloopers for everyone I've
liked the whole year and it played for
the whole school and at the end of
everyone's individual bloopers it was
like their name and then the nickname
she gave them she like surprised us with
nicknames and she made mine that came up
on a screen for the whole school
miss Slurpee this is garbage then
everybody was like so what's miss lippy
yeah what's miss Larry's deal yeah
anyways yeah I prom and also the taquito
gets a lot of [ __ ] I don't know why it's
[ __ ] girl dude
maybe it's the name or the fact that
it's just like rolling next to the cash
register I don't know what it is but
dude they're [ __ ] good
they're so good if you're listening to
this right now
don't shut it off listen to the rest of
the podcast but then go to your nearest
7-eleven and give them Monterrey chicken
and cheese taquito get a little side
packet of ranch baby boys yeah I was I
was a buffalo chicken guy two of the I
would just cuz I'd go to of the buffalo
chicken John's I didn't even when they
first came out I couldn't remember the
name taquito and in Philly everything's
a John so we just go y'all let me get
through them buffalo chicken John's they
throw them in that little sleeve dude
you get two for 129 I know their pizzas
not too bad either while we're on the
[ __ ] subject their pizza dollar slice
ain't too shabby they're chicken nuggets
aren't bad 7-eleven wings the wings are
good the wings are alright and this I
mean I'm this might solidify me as a
trash okay I'm leaving my flag my 711
flag I the way you said that you know
it's whatever man dude I love it you're
mine so you did you did film and TV in
high school did you ever work for a
local production company um not a local
production company that's what I did
when I went to LA for the summer
respectable yeah you weren't weddings or
anything like that no some videographer
stand behind some [ __ ] doofus with a
camcorder no I don't like to football
games for the high school and film those
and do like local news I get embarrassed
just now of all this [ __ ] that you said
that was the thing you've like cringed
at this will make you feel better we had
Joe list on and Joe list after he
graduated high school would go to his
high school football games and try to
charge the field after victories no yeah
that's like that's insane graduated high
school we said I'm like just 32 to
yelling at teenagers he's like you gotta
take the field you gotta take the field
they were like what dude all right I got
why we're so on food I mean um have you
ever microwaved bacon um I have but it's
not our thing okay fair enough
uh everybody's been in a pinch I get it
yeah yeah it's my thing what are you
talking about be honest someone told me
about it recently and I tried it and it
did come out really good no man no
really crispy okay really crispy what do
you do it on the grill that's not why I
see this is my problem with Foley
Foley's not doing it because he thinks
it tastes better full he's doing it so
he can eat it faster it's a time thing
with Foley bacon on the pan you get like
three slices and it takes ten minutes I
hate that [ __ ] there's always a couple
left over but the best part about
putting it on the pan is any of the
leftover gravy and the grease you get
going yeah I mean the grease yeah you
can make gravy and like the
possibilities are endless
don't you have bacon grease yeah you can
put your eggs in the grease and now you
have eggs that taste slightly like bacon
mm-hmm for sure for sure for sure I
would I just like to note that at 2:27
p.m. Kim referred to grease
like that stricken from the records let
the record show which makes me think
that your drizzle of the gravy on other
things what it's done alright um have
you any member of your family ever been
involved in or seen a monster truck show
yes yeah they're fun yeah that's we went
one day in college because it was like
sunday sunday sunday on TV and we were
like yo it's [ __ ] sunday like let's
[ __ ] go dude it was filled with hot
chicks which was blew our minds and it
was so much fun it's really fun it's
dude they know how to work a crowd like
people they get out of their cars
they're scream it's a it's a whole thing
yeah alright have you ever been have you
ever eaten at a Long John Silver's yes
but again not our thing okay alright
you're getting more like we're like
woods trash you're getting more hood
trash okay okay all right
trying to figure figure out the line
here I would like to apologize again
that is unfortunately a fully thing as
well John Stauffer is over since we were
kids it was the big thing we would go
it's not garbage we are we would go
my brother was obsessed with their hush
puppies but when we were both obsessed
with is you know like when you fry fish
or chicken and that beer batter little
pieces of batter will break off so long
john silver's and all the stuff was in a
tray you guys helped to the grease trap
like I'm waiting for it to come out
Oh there'd be a whole bunch of the mixed
in it we used to refer to them as
crunchies can we get a bag of crunchies
and we'd get like a little french fry
thing of just beer batter now wonder
what happened yeah and you wonder why
your weight problem is where it is today
you're eating your own meal at Long John
you're ordering off menu at ljs dude
what are you doing he's like I know the
managers totally back there
Tony the fat kids are here and they're
looking for the crumbles okay oh my god
yeah that's true
that's guts that's that it depends like
you can either be like good good
wholesome fun or like if you're fishing
because you need dinner it can be a
little different right right well let's
do levels here now that you guys brought
up Long John Silver's I would like you
and there is a difference okay it gets
okay to trashy what is your number one
fast-food establishment okay so I have
two number ones and ones classy ones
trashy okay there is only really one
acceptable answer but go ahead okay fine
if there's one acceptable answer I'm
going Taco Bell that's not the
acceptable answer I don't think I'll
give you talk forgot about the only only
correct answer is Wendy's everything
else is trash
no chick-fil-a he's gotta buy a mic to
pick filiz got him by a mile
dude the service the food it's clean
yeah you don't feel like complete
garbage when you're done
yeah chick-fil-a is my number two but
that only happened after I could
pronounce hors d'oeuvres
[Laughter]
what if where does what about like Sonic
that's what I was looking for that's a
real garbage that's a gimmick I mean
that was a gimmick like they showed up
and we went like once or twice and it's
like not good and it's yeah it's not
worth it we would eat at checkers a lot
ooh
checkers is all right checkers okay
that's a prize bro you can't find a good
one in New York but you get down in the
south a little bit you drive by a
checkers do yourself a favor stop the
family off there for a little picnic not
ignore the rats and hepatitis but eat
the fries yeah all right I got another
one we're actually another food one
growing up if it was your if it was your
birthday and you were having a party or
whatever would you have a cookie cake
for your birthday I have had a cookie
cake not every time but I have yes boxes
yeah yeah we got to get him at the mall
or something they were never unlike a
standalone bill
Yetta like it was if you were going to
the mauled by your [ __ ] cakes
you got something twisted oh yeah
alright let's move on a little bit here
do you currently own or in your house
right now
does anybody have any fireworks right
now in your house I'm sure in the garage
yes okay that brings me oh sorry please
you said do you have a second
refrigerator in that garage yes she
ain't down yet
that's clean [ __ ] living right there
can we ask everybody two questions we
asked them about the milk for dinner and
it's very big for Kevin and I the garage
fridge is huge it's a big are you
garbage thing the garage the meat and
the beer yes thank you
people are getting second to fridge
people just get it you try to talk to
people that didn't grow up with one
especially like if you grew up an
apartment I get it or a townhouse or so
but if you've had a garage and didn't
have a refrigerator in there they their
minds don't can't comprehend it it's so
weird it's necessary yes she's crawling
back baby
people always say ah [ __ ] people always
think it's like oh that's rich people
[ __ ] but it's like nobody ever buys two
refrigerators it's like given to you or
you find it or something one of the
refrigerators wasn't working so you're
like you know what this will be for our
vegetables and then the one that's
stronger is for the meat yes exactly and
it's like poor people never can never
bring themselves to throw something else
as expensive or as big as a refrigerator
it's a Jacuzzi now of course yeah it's
always given to a brother-in-law or
something like that and they come get it
that's when you know you're real trash
when somebody comes to get something oh
so-and-so is coming to take the washer
I'm gonna pick up the couch you're like
what yeah have you ever rented have you
ever sold jet skis sold it now have you
ever ridden a jet ski yes fair I'm gonna
give you a pass because Florida and jet
skis you they're not they're trashy you
know into the motorcycles of the water
for sure but you know
they're not I think you think if you've
ever been on one your trashy which isn't
the case we have a pontoon boat in the
back that's come up before that's just
for alcoholics don't want to get off
land that's what you say in the yard did
I just say it was in the front yard
right now yeah it's right next to an
arrow archery board oh my god and in
front of the yard where there is tiki
bar and an above-ground pool in the back
that's game set and match right there
holy [ __ ] we have an above-ground pool
wait a minute wait a minute then my
parents built a deck around only I got
one a hundred feet away from me the
above-ground in-ground that's what
that's called
[Laughter]
technically you do jump into it I'll
give you that you do jump down into the
pool three feet into it and that's it oh
my god
do you own a pocket knife not anymore I
used to fair enough I've ever bought a
gun at Walmart no were you guys a gun
family growing up yeah yeah we have a
shotgun that's admirable I feel a
shotguns legit yeah yeah yeah we're like
you know what you can kill someone but
it's not insane it's not sawed off as it
does the handle sawed it off with like
some kind of weird wrapping around it a
snub nose up nose on it no all right how
do you feel about coleslaw love it
deviled eggs love him garbage looking
Kevin Spacey's have you ever taken
ketchup and mayonnaise and make Russian
dressing
she didn't even finish that Jesus Christ
you put a little relish it oh that's
Thousand Island just so everybody knows
a little more relish a new year a
thousand pounds
have you ever owned or ordered a Snuggie
yes I got one for Christmas for my mom
one year yeah me too I got an Eagles one
which is like the ultimate rash growing
up what brand of bicycle did you ride
you remember the name brand of it no um
we did a lot of beach bikes and I had a
scooter that was called the she-devil
I raised okay a razor scooter was it
name-brand razor no name-brand raises
all right or was it a level as a
name-brand so it wasn't a razor scooter
it was a brand called she does you devil
that looked like a rings in North Korean
razors yeah ever worked with a local
band my stepdad isn't a local band
what's he play oh my god you're the lead
singer zoom over here
what does he have a long hair and also
what is the name of the band has long
hair has highlights in it and the name
of the band I mean he might not play it
anymore but it was pretty recent last
few months it was called payback do they
play covers or originals cover if
payback isn't a stepdad cover band I
don't know what the [ __ ] is that's great
this is too funny I love it have you
ever gotten any henna art any henna
tattoos yep so did I got my initials on
me dude that's all everyone shut up oh
you didn't get offensive and might be
this good at the game check your broken
blinds were outside love it
have you ever pawned anything yes
absolutely
what was it in why our money gold
jewelry laptop skateboard circle suits
parted in the way of you got it back or
pawn it is and you sold it cuz that's
the thing I'm not Pawn Stars there we
say you want to pawn it or sell it
nobody ever wants to pawn it there's no
nobody's ever coming back to pick it up
yeah it was gone
I want the guitar in North Carolina one
time did you ever go back to get it
still still sitting there waiting for
you it's still working off the pavement
still got cheeto dust on it how do you
feel about peanut butter um it's okay
chunky or smooth uh either way did you
guys have Nutella growing up no yeah
that was [ __ ] that was ritzy showers
I don't even know about it until like a
year ago I swear to god I'm the same my
mom used to just buy those Ferrero
Rocher and we used to dig the Middle's
after the out of those you know those
things are pretty classy too but they're
the trashiest of the classy it's like if
you want to feel classy and you have an
extra $2.00 you know what I mean yeah
that's true yeah well it's your money
stuff you know what I mean yeah yeah the
Rothschilds aren't buying those no the
most trashy that was at the counter I
don't know if they had them in Florida
but we have these things up here there
are their little cherries in chocolate
they're little chocolate-covered
cherries those things are garbage my dad
every time he walks into a 7-eleven let
me have told them real quick yep those
are so good they're in that liquid yeah
it's so good it's so good do you
currently own or does any member of your
family currently own a hard copy of the
Kelly Blue Book yes my stepdads
definitely owns a Kelly Blue Book them
amount of times I've heard him say those
words yeah is there also any body is
there any is there any auto traders in
your house right now
probably yeah I would guess that if you
offered a million dollars to find one
I'd dig one up yeah and also had you
guys ever owned an RV or a camper of any
kind we had we had a pop-up camper in
the back
the pop-up filter is the trash we had a
pop up camper in the backyard for about
a year and then my dad was sleeping in a
tent and in December it got cold he
didn't have a house my birth father and
then my stepdad felt bad for him so he
gave him the pop-up camper and then my
dad destroyed it somehow holy [ __ ] all
sounds legit to me fair enough yet yeah
there was one of those pop-up campers
sitting at my cousin's house for like
two years and it was like half down and
half open it was like obviously busted
and my uncle for some reason thought
that we were going to think it was the
greatest thing ever one day he went out
there and cleaned it out and like raised
it obviously you guys want to go inside
it was a [ __ ] hornet's nest in there
that could have killed the entire did
you think we're nuts he made it he made
it rhyme with corn nuts yeah you're so
fat you know even you think insects or
food I mean when you know it's yeah I
think all right this is the problem
you're saying it fast it sounds like
you're saying it correctly but when you
slow it down and put a pause in the
middle that you're not that's not even a
thing or nuts yeah this is like when I
used to say old timers oh I want to bag
a [ __ ] wrench coordinates now thank
you that there's a trip to 7-eleven in
my future all right just a few more
questions here keeping you got one yes I
got lost for a second have you ever
jumped off a trampoline into a pool yes
that's good clean fun as a teenager yeah
I got hit for that have you ever gone on
vacation to a tropical island that came
back with braided hair or cornrows in
your hair yes but I'll veto this that's
that's only trashy of white girls do it
she's technically you know from she's
technically has Island blood in her so
it's it's she's getting in touch with
her roots a little bit you could argue
right fair enough
overruled I appreciate it I like it um
okay dude in any of your houses that
you've lived in was there ever a garage
that was too full of stuff to pull
[Laughter]
it fits in the garage but it's like it
looks like like the stuff has a shape of
a car like yeah it's in like an inch on
each my stepdad makes us get out in the
driveway because we can't open the doors
and wow that was real big or to get out
to like to get in my mom would be my mom
like let me pull out and then you can
hop in open the doors sometimes when we
drive my mom's car we can only drive it
for a little bit before we have to stop
cuz ice to cool down before we can keep
driving garbage tip for that I had that
for a long time the gallon of water
gallon of water and turn the heat on
turn the heat on when I guess you're in
Florida so it's tough do you know how
many times I've been cruising down the
highway with the heat on five degree
weather with the windows open just we
used to play in high school it was
called hell in Florida we'd turn with me
and my cousin's would play in this car
we'd get in the car after school that
would be sitting the parking lot all day
we get in the car like 3:30 in the
afternoon after the hottest day of the
year and we pack ourselves in the car
we'd roll the windows that put the heat
on blast and whoever asked to roll the
window down first loss
Christ that's a crying monster called
hell and what by the time we got home
we'd open the doors and the car would be
steaming oh holy [ __ ] another level of
garbage ladies and gentlemen okay I got
one have you ever been drunk at a TGI
Fridays or Applebee's yep does your
phone right there as they ever lived in
a house where there was a dehumidifier
in the basement no there's no basements
employed no basements it was ever a
dehumidifier in the house no okay do
your parents drink yeah so what do they
drink ah I think we got something
[Laughter]
my seven dreams michelob ultra okay and
my mom will drink vanilla crown oh man
that's pretty trashy any boxed wine in
your house right now now they're not big
wine drinkers here is she keep the bag
to the crown yes or there's no purple
Crown Royal bag in your house right
there's a purple Crown Royal bag with
like safety pins and [ __ ] in it that's
so for some reason trashy people see
that and they go get a hold onto it the
same thing is the garage fridge ago I
got onto this for something my mom was
like oh my god is velvet also are there
any empty cigar boxes in your house
that's always a dead giveaway yeah it's
like a little flashlight in a pocket
knife in it yep I don't know if I ask
you this have you ever owned anything
that was reversible reversible jacket
reversible belt
first of all yep I had a few reversible
like oh it's a windbreaker on one side
and a warm jacket on the other hell yeah
yeah that's trash man those things are
awesome
yeah the fall in the winter right now
that my mom come for me two for the
price of one baby oh yeah hippie what do
you got it's got one more okay I got it
I got one on this I'm assuming is a yes
at this point I would be shocked if no
has anyone in your family ever taken a
couch or piece of furniture from the
garbage yeah yeah of course yeah also
have any of your couches have any of
your garages ever had a couch in them
where you hung out on the couch in the
garage no but I think we've had a few
like patios that have had couches Oh an
outdoor couch yikes yikes you got the
outside furniture inside the inside
they're all better all [ __ ] backwards
down there Kim this has been awesome my
final question to you is have you ever
operated a t-shirt gun disappoint I can
see you with a t-shirt gun in your hand
yeah me too
that's hilarious oh my god Kippy what
else you got
that's it guys yeah thanks so much for
listening we appreciate it please make
sure you rate review subscribe on iTunes
also on YouTube as well you can rate you
can subscribe there as well we
appreciate it
buddy this was the best man you were so
open and honest I loved it
definitely garbage I think you might
have dethroned Greg stone Greg stone
yeah you're garbage so far I think so
right here's the thing that I'm taking
away from it you might be the most
garbage but the way you answered the
questions with such like relentlessness
it was like you were like the guy that
we bring in for questioning that won't
break I mean like when the cops show up
it's almost like what took you so long
yeah you're giving us nothing I'm
surprised you weren't smoking a
cigarette like yeah yeah that's what I
loved about it you were like yeah yeah
yeah
they're gonna have to water border to
get any good info out of her or you mean
Michael down the block it was like
interviewing Joe Pesci's character here
from [ __ ] Goodfellas um it's early
you want the the folks out there to know
anything you have coming up anything you
want on the follow at cetera et cetera
um comedies dead but you can follow me
on Twitter add Kimberly Condon on
Instagram and tik-tok at kim Congdon
anything I got coming up on there broad
topics sorry about that no no sobbing
broad topics make sure you check that
out ladies and gentlemen the amazing
Kim cognitum thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it
thank you thanks awesome we will see you
guys next week
on another exciting edition of ru
garbage thanks so much and goodbye